[Music]
right one of my favorites it's a tangy
fruit salad and it's for breakfast would
you believe start off with a chili
now
give it a little rub
so
you can
hear those seeds
being released
get your knife
and come all the way down
turn it over and just slice it
into four
and then
finely chop that chilli
i want this salad slightly hot
so i'm going to use all the chili for
half the seeds the seeds are where the
heat is so the less you use the milder
your dish nicely chopped
next
one of my favorite pastes tamarind paste
this is quite tart quite sour but it's a
wonderful compliment to the sweetness of
the fruit and it goes brilliantly well
with a chili
palm sugar
and this is where it sweetens up
the dressing because it enriches it then
the zest and the juice of a lime cut it
into quarters
and then twist the lime to maximize and
all that juice out now to finish that
dressing off some toasted peanuts
get the pan nice and hot
a little touch of salt
that'll help dry roast the peanuts
even quicker
make sure you get a really nice
dark color on those peanuts because it
will really transform that dressing
to crush your roasted nuts the mess free
way simply wrap them in a clean cloth
and use a rolling pin or a pan to bash
them
crush
that's the hard bit done
now for the fruit and here's an easy way
to prep a pineapple pineapple
take off the top
take off the bottom
and stand it up use a corner knife
and follow down
basically like shaving the pineapple
don't worry about these little spikes
there
the secret behind doing it this way is
not losing half the pineapple there's
nothing wrong with a few brown bits it's
all good fiber
slice the pineapple in half
and then slice down
each quarter
slice
across and chop
delicious
pineapple chunks
next apples and pears diced then to give
a lovely fresh light note the seeded
cucumber
i don't want the seeds in the fruit
salad the cucumber seeds will make it
very watery and
dilute the strength for that wonderful
chili in there
cucumber in
for some sweetness
delicious mango just slice it
nicely get your dressing
and just drizzle that over the fruit
salad
in
the secret of a good fruit salad
is not drowning in the dressing
but really make sure that you've got
that nice coating on all the fruits
don't worry about just having for
breakfast because this is the kind of
tangy fruit salad you can have for lunch
a healthy snack in the afternoon but it
transforms a traditional fruit salad
into something really delicious
spicy fruit salad with a kick of chili
trust me it's an incredible breakfast
and a guaranteed pick me up in the
morning
there's something very scottish about
porridge
it's that kind of sort of great start to
the day
my father used to say
porridge needs salt
and salt only
it separates the men from the boys
didn't really like it who was insistent
salt puts hairs on yours
i used to sneak a couple of sugar lumps
from cafes and put them
in my porridge without him watching
these days my porridge has much more
flavor than just salt it's packed with
fruit nuts and spices add vanilla seeds
to porridge oats or oatmeal
really important just to rub the vanilla
through
the oatmeal makes it nice and fragrant
now a little teaspoon
of cinnamon makes it spicier and then
nutmeg
[Music]
already
that
smells incredible i quite like making
this up week at a time and
jack absolutely loves it now
whole almonds
now if you don't like that kind of
crunch running through the porridge you
can chop these up or blend them to a
powder but i quite like the sort of
texture hazelnut nuts incredibly good
a really nice crunch keep your vanilla
pod in there as well that just gives it
even more lift and of course once it's
baked just pull it out instead of sugar
i'm adding sweetness with fruit fresh
pears and raisins
cranberries are great as well chopped
apricots as well dried apricots in there
dried mango i love dried fruit next pour
in a pint of milk and mix
this can be done the night before left
in the fridge
and then
a couple minutes before you go to bake
it add your cream
now
into your dish
it looks quite liquid
but by the time it bakes
has this really nice rich crust on top
and then
just a nice little nutmeg
on top
now bake at 180 for 30 to 35 minutes
then take the porridge out sprinkle on
demerara sugar and grill to create a
sweet golden crust
and sort of glaze on top
beautiful
literally
for three to four minutes
look at that
that makes me feel proud to be scottish
because it's perfect for a big comfort
family breakfast it's rich it's
sumptuous
and it's just a humble oatmeal
phenomenal especially in the winter my
spice baked porridge with all those nuts
and fruit it's a bowl full of love to
start the day
[Music]
delicious poached pears i love pizza
ready so we're gonna poach them with a
little bit of chili
chili
never heard of that a little bit of
saffron no
no
now pan on
take off a little slice like that so
they stand up nicely and then peel
okay then and then the chili you hold
that up and just go down yep
through
and open that up okay into the water
seeds in as well
a little bit of
water and sugar
what are they holes
saffron is expensive but you only need
the tiniest little bit
a little pinch to make that water go
light and golden star nice how come it's
the chinese you've like sliced it at the
end and it's not put in whole i want all
that flavour coming out of the chili
we're going to make
the most amazing star in east dust sorry
stars dust
should get your star nice in there
seed
up and then
in
see all those little seeds yeah
and then
you start grinding
a little teaspoon of ginger give it a
nice mix thank you meg and that's gonna
dust the top of the pears once they're
cooked
ryan get your pears
drop them in there
and that's what we're going to sprinkle
mmm
ginger that's darwinis wow the rice is
that
very good
that's lovely isn't it so once they're
cooked
cool down sprinkle that over the top
right have you guys got homework yes see
you guys come back shortly thank you
turn that down and let them fall
okay thank you guys
after an eight minute simmer our pears
should be ready now just get your knife
on put the knife through and see how
easy the knife is
so that means they're soft and cooked
now you can leave them in that overnight
two or three days all right and they
just get darker
and more beautiful
the good thing about the cooking liquor
is that you don't throw that away
because you can use that again for
re-poaching
beautiful
i mean they look impressive they smell
delicious donna don't they
[Music]
look at the colors nice lovely isn't it
colors are an amazing one
and just
smells delicious
and then take your little
star and east dust
and just
dust
over look at that nice looking you think
of the
flavor and the texture of avocado rich
phenomenal i want to make it a little
bit more vibrant black sesame seeds a
nice pinch of chili flakes i quite like
it hot
a touch of salt
and a touch of pepper
so that nice dry combination of the
lemon zest black sesame seeds and the
heat the chili this is light healthy
quick
but so tasty
sourdough bread
three nice chunky thick slices open them
up
lightly season them
little touch of olive oil
brings the whole crust to life
rub all that seasoning in
but you can use chipotle you can use
a baguette but the richness from the
sourdough with the silky creaminess of
avocado is mind-blowing and then get the
grill up to temperature
and push these down
go the extra mile we've all put bread in
a toaster but the difference
of grilling the bread this way
is extraordinary that nice smoky
charcoal flavor
off with the gas beautiful
now the avocado you've got to treat them
with love respect press on the end here
as your thumb
softens you can tell that avocado is
ripe never press here you just end up
bruising it
slice down
until you feel that stone in the middle
and then just roll around and then it's
just a little gentle twist
off
stone
and out cut them into quarters
the back of your knife
peel back that skin if the avocado is
nice and ripe it should just all fall
away slice
just take your quarters fan them out
and push them into the bread
the ripe of the avocado the better the
flavor but look for ones free from soft
spots and blemishes which can suggest
bruising
get your lemon
squeeze
that will stop the avocado from
discoloring
and then get your crunch ready to go on
top
sprinkle
in a very
generous
light way you've got the fragrance from
the lemon zest
the crunch from the sesame seed the heat
that little chili flake which just wakes
up the avocado
they look
expensive
that for me
is a delicious light start to the day
avocado on sourdough toast with lemon
and black sesame sprinkle
you